البدايه من مقال للكاتب ديفيد روث كوبف في
موقع ديلي بيست يقول فيه ان العلاقه بين
اداره بايدن وحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو اصبحت
مسمومه واضاف ان كبار المسؤولين يعملون
ليلا نهارا من اجل التوصل الى حل للحرب
بين اسرائيل وحماس في غزه والواقع ان
العديد من مبادرات الحل تم تقويضها بشكل
مباشر من قبل نتنياهو
وحكومته اشارت صحيفه بوست الى استمرار
الجمود في مجلس الامن الدولي حول قرار
لوقف القتال في غزه ما يسلط الضوء على
عزله واشنطن على المسرح العالمي ويقول
ريتشرد كوان خبير الامم المتحده في مجموعه
الازمات الدوليه ليس سرا ان السفير ليندا
توماس جرينفيلد ترغب في التوصل الى اتفاق
لكن الامر يعود في النهايه الى رغبات
بايدن الخاصه وفق
قوله نشرت صحيفتها ارس تحليلا بقلم انشل
فيفر قال فيه ان نتنياهو الذي تدنت شعبيته
يحاول تصوير الرئيس بايدن على انه اوباما
الثاني وتقديم نفسه للاسرائيليين باعتباره
الوحيد القادره على الوقوف في وجه
الامريكيين معرضا بذلك العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه الاكثر اهميه لاسرائيل للخطر
من اجل مصالحه الشخصيه ويؤكد الكاتب انها
استراتيجيه بقاء يائسه محكوم عليها
بالفشل في صحيفه جورسليم بوست مقال يتوقع
زلزالا سياسيا كبيرا في اسرائيل بعد هجوم
حماس ويرى ان ما حدث تسبب في تحول جذري في
المشهد السياسي في اسرائيل يصف المقال
الوضع بالقول ان الثقه البلاد بنفسها
تضررت واهتز الاحساس بالامان وتحطمت الثقه
بالقاده السياسيين
والعسكريين اشارت صحيفه الجارديان الى ان
عدد الفلسطينيين المحتجزين لدى اسرائيل
دون تهمه وصل الى اعلى مستوى له وسط موجه
مكثفه من الاعتقالات بعد هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر وتقول جماعات الحقوقيه ان السلطات
الاسرائيليه تشن حمله قمع عشوائيه ضد
الفلسطينيين ويتم تصنيف المعتقلين على
انهم تهديد امني حتى بسبب منشوراتهم
البسيطه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي اعتبر المؤرخ جون كوربل في
مقاله بصحيفه تاينا ديلي الصينيه انه لا
يوجد صراع مستعص على الحل مضيفا ان دعم
الولايات المتحده الكامله لاسرائيل يعني
انها تخرج نفسها من اللعبه وعليه فان
الفرصه باتت حه امام الصين للجمع بين
الخصوم بعد ان نجحت في تطوير علاقاتها مع
العالم العربي واسرائيل وبات بوسعها ان
تحقق تغييرا بالغ الاهميه في منطقه اتسمت
بالخلافات لفتره
[موسيقى]
طويله